negli episodi precedenti di residenti vo
quando machete che ci si mette a ridere
e giudicati io ve l'ho detto da
residenti con sedi in poi ho preso tante
di quelle robe che come faccio a essere
vivo non lo so ma se tipo faccio così
due volte morta cos'è qatar a gas o
facebook be back again paris back seller
friends ragazzi non so dove devo andare
per salvare la partita perché mi sto
pagando in mano che il nome troppo moio
così che c'è qua buschi degli angeli
forse perché devo io comunque devo
trovare della roba da mettere qua dentro
però effettivamente io di bussole
l'angelo trovato solo il tesoro che non
c'entra niente
gli oggetti non ho nulla quindi devo
ancora trovare la roba giusta per poter
fare sta cosa qua che non solo non ho
idea di dove si trovi di questo mondo
nicolò sono andato lì che si sono andato
di cose che ho per lei chiave del
cortile per riuscire ok nouvelles vin
bon a quello buna sanguis virginis
affacciò galaxys ho trovato nella cucina
ragazzi intero solo in cucina e ucciso
sempre qua cosa mi service o sanguis
virginis presente questi mettono il
sangue di vergine nella nella bottiglia
quindi roba che fa cioè vomito nel però
loro lo bevono
ecco perché io sono astemio cioè nel
senso mi già mi fa schifo il vino
normale figuriamoci così c è come tidona
natanz in amd che bevono proprio questo
è sporco di rosso c'è tutta la torre sto
spiegando tipo alla saab ago ma quando
mai
allora ragazzi la chiave di alcune mine
però oggi però aperto a manhattan ha
vinto sul campo sono fatta ei due sono
stato bravissimo mettiate sono scappato
non anche visto che dopo la li non me ne
frega niente non me ne frega niente di
postare video che bello il non il
castello è il giardino anche castello
località però giardino più bello
questa è la cucina il prima dove prima
si è rotta la finestra è un giardino
interno molto carino allora con poi c'è
un'altra forte invece che mi sa che
aperta attenzione che ciò paura mira
subito york che cosa finisce male eccola
la mills bianca lam il film bianco
insomma io la seguo perché un pochettino
sono curioso e non è che non mi voglio
far vedere ma allo stesso tempo simili
pianta verde a caso che cosa hai fatto
bene è morta perché mi rompeva il cazzo
però fa niente finché non se ne accorge
che sono qua è un problema ma 4
accorgersene adesso mappa del castello
quindi detto tutto vedo tutto sala del
piacere ma fammi il piacere veramente ci
manca solo che chiave di alcina tra
l'altro che ci manca solo quello allora
questa è chiusa sommità che c'è una
porta aperta o chiusa fuori questa
manina ialca colognola e vengo lì ma
solo perché voglio vedere la reazione in
diretta non può cenare jacuzzi qua c'è
qualcosa no poi c'è qualcosa c ok non so
dove sia andata la tipa
c'è un'altra porta qua c'è un pendolo o
c'è qualcosa che è l'unica porta che
posso vedere teoricamente è questa
corretto yes e cosa ho fatto totti non
lo so dove sei
e sparita arquà va bene dove se n'è
andato a non ne ho idea però siccome si
teletrasporta pure lei non so come le
donne conversano deliziate dal signor a
cavallo sono corteggiate da lui
dispregiativo non farsi notare
così che il vino possa fare cagare da
questa una cosa che ho sempre pensato
anch'io
quindi io devo ruota ruotare immagino
sapevano nuotare in modo tale che
vengano corteggiate ma anche ma aspetta
che non ho capito bene il modo le donne
conversan deliziate dal signore a
cavallo sono corteggiate
l'amministrativo non farsi notare e così
dopo ok quindi loro con boe quindi loro
le devo le devo girare una con l'altra
ok c'è una band verso l'altra quindi
giusto così sono corteggiate dal signore
a cavallo quindi signora cavallo va
nella direzione in mezzo no mezzano
quindi nuovo quindi così
ok e gli sperati invece chiedono al
signor a cavallo delle cose quindi
giusto così
what's my friends proprio il fabi che
trova la solution
ecco dov'è andata la zia però le
centrata con tutto il maestro bene ma
pulita la darei troppa niente comunque
bellissimo con i giorni
non è vero sono morto come fatta partina
caduta così senza partito sei veramente
spider man
se ti sei beccato del piano tranciato le
dita che hanno ficcato delle orobie
tanto non umori mai c'è veramente cos'è
sta roba è un collezionabile spettatore
lo sapevo hanno inserito anche le
citazioni di sgarbi tra le achievement
sta cosa incredibile è facile ma che
cazzo lo dico io però fa niente pieno di
vino o queste vino e ragazzi non fatevi
strane idee per quello quello quello non
è vino vado di qua
certo definiti bene lo devo fare fuori
immagino non sono una che visto dove
andato amatori qua lo zio sparito
bene force capezzana mi sono scagliato
nelle mutande ma almeno non si vedono
ok a posto o avete rotto le palle
poi e voce jump square antica se siete
tutti i quali tengono i prigionieri cioè
prigionieri si rompe i [ __ ] polvere
da sparo
let's golf e allora facciamo un fatto
faccio altri due mentre in questa gente
che non sa sui [ __ ] dei giovani che
ha dei forti e mori per palle trani ho
viste non è vero vlc è un concerto a
herat audaci e morto subito m manco
morto subito
adesso durano mesi fa ad onna minchiam
ha fatto una lingua video curare mi
saraga e si fa migliore trasporto devo
farmi i soldi per potenziali la pistola
e poi posso dare la metà dei corpi erano
in testa gente sostanzialmente e mori
quanto fastidio a boras
very nice posso andare è finita è per
nudo legge questi ascensori moderni 2021
criticato sono fuori cioè sono fuori
sono albacora ma se ciò che lo
spaventapasseri faccio punti
cos'è un pianta verde nice
be nice e venus che stiamo andando
c'è un telefono pronto vodafone mi fa un
sacco ridere ragazzi se ci penso perché
all'inizio della mia carriera youtube
ica quando rispondeva al telefono nei
videogiochi dicevo pronto vodafone
adesso sono partner di cosa con una cosa
incredibile vabbè comunque il telefono
che squilla non ho capito dove qua devo
fare olio cuore verso passo da una
minchia risponde lei
la mif in bianco lei non risponde non
gliene frega niente ii fu ma davanti a
te devi spalle madre milan non era visto
un desolata ma purtroppo quel mentecatto
di heisenberg si è fatto sfuggire
italwin ma povero iceberg perché adesso
e nel castello e sta dando del filo da
torcere alle mie fini hai visto avrò
trovato sono qua però fa niente che
tanto non mi vedo ma tre miranda
sì certo che comprendo l'importanza
della cerimonia la cerimonia di nome
quant'era stai calma altro da veri
tamponato la figlia 2000 pagana davvero
molto molto cara pensate che mi avete
fatto di mi avete in crocifisso
mi avete staccato le dita tutto mi avete
fatto e non siete riusciti a uccidermi
non si sa come non si sa come veramente
e da e da residenti non 7 che questo qua
non si sa come può essere vivo che non
avete idea di cosa è successo di forse
ce l'avete mi sono staccato pensavo
fosse ancora lei min chiara un manichino
cross dove sei
lo so adesso la cerchiamo sicuro cioè
nella foto che ti stai portando
dall'inizio non ho capito perché però
cassetto no
chiusa dall altro lato dovadola chiave
di alci dov'è ma dove astana ma
[ __ ] due ore ho trovata
ho trovato la chiave di alcina che
sarebbe la chiave che apre la metà
bongiorno morto
tutto questo a causa di una mozione che
non è neanche qui è loggato miserabile
co vista ingrato si introduce nella mia
casa bonato vogliono dei morti ferretti
di toccare le mie che qualcuno ha
scoccato rete italiana come oggi è stato
respinto il piano solo nessuno riusciva
di questa tregua per il resto ti sta
nero e ti farò a pezzi ok e di tutto
questo non riuscivo io che ti pare è una
tregua
grazie meno male perché non lo sapeva da
che parte farmi va bene continuano a
uccidermi ignoro il motivo però andiamo
avanti ragazzo sta bene siamo
o a possibili nuovi sottotipo le
prigioni vicino
ok secondo me possiamo tranquillamente
andare al piano di sopra e un ascensore
per perdere e affrontare a viso aperto
la milf in bianco perché secondo me con
luci rossi però vorrei vorrei
assolutamente potenziarli l'arma prima
questa cosa è molto importante perché la
pistola potenziata in residenti volevo
che è un bijoux quando poi potenziati
l'ardire di 20 voli erano 21 prima
potenza sempre la piccola però non ti
lascerò scappare ma dove la camerata
mantelli è come carta sparano e infine
rai mike youtube
e vabbè mi sembrava strano che mi avesse
lasciato scappare per dove vado adesso
che non è che lo profanate che mi avete
rubato la figlia
per questo come ho scavato fatto giro
tira da con l'altra mano con l'altra
mano fuori attaccata lei brava brava
riattaccate la faccia come grazie mano
mozzata e doveva devi aprire la porta
non si apre nicchia
devo resistere finché non si apre la
picchia che casino ma veramente dove la
zia la zia
ecco la forca trojan che è male che mai
ma tu non puoi usare la tua mano destra
non posso mettermi la la cura non posso
curarmi tirati all'acqua sono morto da
che volevamo di qua c'è qualcosa no va
bene
sono morto morto
non posso usare la mano destra morto
uccidimi come solo tu sai fare
e lo scopo di spingere non l'ha proprio
ben capito dove devo andare anche ha
fatto il buco levi abbia in via video
vito d'amico video capito ho capito come
si fa ho capito ho capito vaso dritto di
qui certo la fota una parola lavoro lo
ne è una parolona in italia non esiste
apri non sola mano a picco a sinistra
dove sto andando lui che non lo so
maschera della mestizia non è proprio il
momento di cercare maschere corto nero
che faccio ridere non ho perso un
braccio in tutto questo e non posso più
dà la pistola con la uso con una
sinistra ecco riattaccano bravo a musina
perfetto sempre così bravo bravo non
vedo come possa funzionare
vai prova funziona fa tutto la moglie la
attacca anche l'atac funziona perfetta
altro che chirurghi prova e vedi che un
po brown altro che c'era nessuno questo
castagno bellissima storia e perché se
non avrei mai potuto usare la pistola
non possono tagliare il braccio è
possibile
va bene allora c'è la chiara la chiave
che apre un sacco di polo sono pagato ma
meno ma cronisti in spazza
ma qui il tempo di recuperare tracce
dopo già dovute alle armi porca [ __ ]
piero giunti anche qui
e mori come ho fatto il giro subito ce
n'era uno dietro di me incasinatissimo
sottocosto o finito che ho solo cinque
colpi di pistola
c'è veramente loggiati tutti tutti gli
usati non posso ammazzare solo più uno
poi ho finito quindi colpi di pistola
grazie
o forse li posso creare dall'inventario
camminano non ogni corso che rendono più
scarti a non finiti quindi niente mappa
del castello dependance perché ok adesso
vedo tutto un po meglio
ora ho la maschera quindi me ne servono
altre tre perché se ho altre tre
maschere posso andare nel salone
principale sbloccare la porta proprio
essere un al 33 raga prova a vedere di
sopra se c'è qualcosa ma
mi sa che ci ricolleghiamo esatto non
entra in questa no questa diversa ok più
che la chiave della cina per altre robe
grazie delle munizioni perché veramente
stavo già a secco attenzione al rossetto
la signora è sparito chiunque lo
trovassi è pregato di portarlo nel suo
bagno ed è molto costoso la governante
va bene ho sentito rumori brutti che
cazzo anche un pianoforte e che tutto
passi versi c'è qualcuno che erutta non
capitolare al suo demonia a luca mi stai
bene solo morto mai ce ne sono altri
sicuro o forse no
ok si smaterializzano finissimo sfera
con fiori e spade va bene la sfera posso
mettere la posso mettere al piano di
sotto al posto di esatto dove c'è il
castello
devo tornare al piano di sotto a cell
piano principale per dal mercante devo
tornare sostanzialmente però come
diavolo ci torno da qua non lo so non ho
più colti o solo il fucile porco che
volete andare assolutamente a uomini
contro me di fabbrico però fabbricarsi
un casino perché mi servono pezzi di
ingranaggi che non ho ragazze mi spunta
qualcuno sono morto
sono cosi dimmi che ci sono cose di
momento ps dice meno male e ne trovo
sempre un sacco e sono sempre alta
accordo cioè figura di quantica chieri
gli stronzi ci sono in giro scarti ha
definiti meno male ma li faccio poi tre
corpi poi corpi perché non vogliamo nome
ne servono di più mannaia interagisci ma
non lo so non sono capace a leggere note
ma porto demonio gli enigmi pure sarebbe
fiero mio padre di questa cosa ma sto
facendo veramente un lavoro da cani
[Musica]
bello bellissimo video però è lì l'ho
subito legionario dinho o il rimorchio
easy quando sai suonare lo stemma di
ferro eccolo qua con questa fra tutte le
altre porte tra l'altro fantastico non
mi sbuca a nessuno che mi vuole uccidere
in genere così in presidenti valgono
trovino oggetto figo no meraviglioso
strano molto strano
ora posso tornare nei fatti a farmi i
fatti miei
da qualche parte esatto perché all
aperto
me ne torno da quel asti che fa ci fosse
qualcos'altro
ok c'è qualcosa puo trovare comunque qua
perché nella da come zona rossa
però io torno dentro con la chiave nuova
per aprire tutte le nuove robe prima
d'ora mercante raga perché voglio
assolutamente vedere cosa c'è da
offrirmi visto che posso mettere la
sfera dentro quel coso vediamo cosa mi
offre invece un sacco di roba adesso era
un piacere vederti sano e salvo come
procede tutto bene che hanno solo
tagliato un braccio tutto a posto zio hi
fi sul pal qualcosa prima di proseguire
un sacco di roba fratello benvenuto
benvenuti
fammi mettere australiano spera compiere
spalle con la rai qualcosa di minchia ma
scherzi no vabbè bellissimo ma cosa dici
questo mi chiedevi far arrivare nuova
thema stop 9 gioco dell'anno finito male
tutto il gioco questo solo perché per
sbloccare sta roba deve infatti il
giochino che facevo io quando ero
piccola ed ero al mare per vincere la
pace accordò che sono qui mi sono
accorto che dovevo andare sulla roba per
vincere mica pure difficile mi sono
accorto che sei quasi opera difficile
sta roba non so se te ne sei accorto to
his perfetto rotolare che passione
teschio cremisi
questo dà un sacco di soldi vediamo a
quanto me lo venga quantomeno compra lo
zio naim pure un'occhiata in giro alla
borsello del duca vediamo madonna 8.000
tantissimo però non ho troppa roba da
vendere purtroppo 12 va bene come il
fatto procurarti tale rarità e mickey ha
fatto hanno gioito nola bambino faceva
proprio allora venne scelto potenziali
la l'arma perché secondo me potrebbe
aver senso la livello 2
ok l'arma è potenziata al massimo c'è
più di così non posso fare niente e 4
delle altre robe che posso fare però
ancora non me le prendo il progetto
perché la mia non me ne faccio niente
munizioni del fucile si perché alle
missioni del fucino invece me ne potrei
fare qualcosa però preferisco comprare
munizioni pistola per adesso me ne
compro tantissimi perché certo tipo ii è
posto a esaurito merda però guide fucile
no qui il fucile non potrà comprarli
questa è l'arma che gli ha venduto prima
ok perfetto orario abbiamo tutto allora
bustone l'angelo angelo come sta
maschera della mestizia proprio questa
volo mette comunque ho detto ma perché
non troverà una maschera la mestizia ma
una tra l'altro ce ne sono altre tre va
bene signorino trovata una sola una sola
penso che per trovare tutte io debba
battere i boss
credo non so sto punto deduco che sia
così perché non comunque ho trovato la
chiave per entrare nelle porte nuove
non mi ricordo assolutamente dove
sorgono il problema non è che l'acqua
vedi biblioteca ecco questa può questa
roba qua non ce l'ho biblioteche devo
arrivare qua chiave con sistema di ferro
queste sono che si apra un micro più no
al cina cina sala del piacere se
corriamo subito cerchi di suor piera
[ __ ] non me l'aspettavo mai ma
[ __ ] a predare di andare alla
stazione piacere che la prima corriere
veloce dove la chiave del cina è come
mettere fiori grava si levi apre la
porta quanto tempo a shopping ed anzi
sotto la propria
allora o mascherare piacere siamo alla
seconda del piacere questo questa è
questa la maschera importante dato che
abbiamo una roba da spaccare che sono
spacchiamo robe siamo di pirla ok
e c'è qualcosa qua sotto che non ho
visto ma chi è salve ho sentito anche un
rumorino è prima del solo rumorino cit
però non so armeli a minchia dimmi che
trovo un fucile bazooka a tre posti
no vabbè munizioni fucili vai vai
c'erano pace roba almeno per ora è
successo
no non ridere anche base uscire i 43 non
si pu ci sta porta non è una porta un
muro fatiscente la cui sorella morta e
spaccare il muro questa è sta roba bomba
bomba da spaccare il muro con la bolla
hai rotto il cazzo da fare qui ecco devo
spaccare con la bomba spacca duro come
volta ha spaccato la corrida non ho
detto mai manda all'aria la caccia sul
gas e quindi a chi oggi per me sono
contento di finirlo di fini residenti
voli in punti dove uno dice ma che
casanova finire qua che lo so lo so che
sono private prof
mi piace dare alla suspense e noi vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi schede al canale
lasciato un bel commento questo tu cosa
ne pensate su come pensate che andrà a
finire che so io cercherò di visti di
guardare un po tutti i commenti perché
mi interessa sapere che cosa pensate
della trama anche perché mi sto facendo
anche io le mie idee non è come sempre
ci rivediamo ad un procione dei ragazzi
[Musica]